S
TO KIDS AND 2 THIRDS OF THEM
ARE USING TICK-TOCK EVERY DAY.
AISHAH: THEY ARE TRYING TO MAKE
THE CITIZEN'S FOR A PROCESS
MORE WORK BY MAKING IT EASIER,
THE CITIZENSHIP TEST WILL BE
MULTIPLE-CHOICE.
3 YEARS AGO "FOX AND FRIENDS"
CELEBRATED WHAT IT MEANS TO
BECOME AN AMERICAN AT THE FIRST
NATURALIZATION CEREMONY ON FOX
SQUARE.
>> I WILL PERFORM WORK.
>> OF NATIONAL IMPORTANCE.
UNDER CIVILIAN DIRECTION WHEN
REQUIRED BY THE LAW.
AND THAT I TAKE THIS OBLIGATION
FREELY.
WITHOUT ANY MENTAL RESERVATION.
OR PURPOSE OF EVASION.
SO HELP ME GOD.
CONGRATULATIONS.
AISHAH: THEY SERVE THEIR
COUNTRY BEFORE THAT.
A SIMPLE TEST THAT SHOWS HOW
MUCH THEY WANTED TO BECOME AN
AMERICAN.
THEY STUDY TO ANSWER A LOT OF
QUESTIONS.
THEY ARE ASKED TEN OF THE
QUESTIONS AT RANDOM AND THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION'S PLAN
PLANS ON CHANGING THE TEST THE
MULTIPLE CHOICE IN 2024.
LET'S LOOK AT THIS.
THE FIRST FIVE QUESTIONS, THE
FIRST CITIZENSHIP TEST, WHAT IS
THE SUPREME LAW OF THE LAND?
WHAT DOES THE CONSTITUTION DO?
THE IDEA OF SELF-GOVERNMENT IS
IN THE FIRST THREE WORDS OF THE
CONSTITUTION.
WHAT ARE THESE WORDS?
WHAT IS AN AMENDMENT?
WHAT DO WE CALL THE FIRST WE 10
AMENDMENTS TO THE CONSTITUTION?
THAT IS WHAT IS IN THERE NOW.
WHY WOULD THEY WANT TO WATER
DOWN THIS PROCESS.
SHOULDN'T IT BE HARD?
LAWRENCE: WHEN WE HAVE 14,000
PEOPLE ILLEGALLY CROSSING INTO
THE COUNTRY EVERY DAY WE HAVE
TO DO SOMETHING WITH THEM.
IF YOU READ CLOSELY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION WANTS TO ADJUST
THE NATURALIZATION TEXT BECAUSE
THEY SAY WE'VE GOTTEN FEEDBACK
FROM PEOPLE INVOLVED IN THE
PROCESS.
THAT IS PEOPLE WHO THOUGHT IT
WAS TOO HARD.
THE NATURALIZATION PROCESS IS
JUST THAT, TO NATURALIZE PEOPLE
FROM OTHER COUNTRIES INTO THE
AMERICAN EXPERIENCE AND ENSURE
THEY ARE IN A PATH TO BECOMING
AMERICANS.
IT IS AN IDEA, MY FATHER CAME
TO THIS COUNTRY.
HE WAS AN IMMIGRANT, HE SERVED
IN THE MARINES, HE HAD TO LEARN
ENGLISH.
MY GRANDPARENTS COMING OVER
FROM ITALY, IT SHOULD BE A
TRIAL SO YOU ARE CONVERSANT IN
THE LANGUAGE OF THE COUNTRY YOU
WILL NOW BE PART OF.
THAT'S IN THE BEST INTEREST NOT
ONLY OF THE COUNTRY BUT THOSE
COMING INTO THE COUNTRY.
I WORRY ABOUT THIS
NATURALIZATION TEST INTO A FAST
PASS OR TURNSTILE SYSTEM INTO
CITIZENSHIP.
THAT'S NOT WHAT IT WAS INTENDED
TO BE.
IT WAS TO HELP THE NEW
IMMIGRANTS, THE NEW AMERICAN IN
THE COUNTRY.
>> OR UNCLE SERVED IN THE
UNITED STATES NAVY, YOUR FAMILY
FROM PAKISTAN.
TALK ABOUT THAT PROCESS AND
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON THIS?
AISHAH: MY PARENTS HAD TO TAKE
THE TEST.
YOU HAD TO WAIT A FEW YEARS TO
APPLY FOR CITIZENSHIP.
FINALLY GET TO A POINT WHERE
YOU CAN TAKE THE TEST.
IT'S VERY HARD.
I WAS 11 OR 12 YEARS OLD, I
MOVED HERE WHEN I WAS 6.
I HELPED MY MOM STUDY FOR THE
EXAM.
I REMEMBER THINKING AS A
12-YEAR-OLD THESE QUESTIONS ARE
HARD.
KUDOS TO EVERY ONE OF THOSE
SERVICEMEMBERS ABLE TO PASS AND
BECOME A CITIZEN.
IT'S THE MOST EMOTIONAL, ONE OF
THE MOST EMOTIONAL MEMORIES I
HAVE.
I REMEMBER IT IN INDIANAPOLIS,
WATCHING MY PARENTS PUT THEIR
HAND OVER THEIR HEART AND TAKE
THE OATH AND FEELING SO PROUD
OF THEM.
AT THE END OF THE DAY WHEN YOU
PUT THIS TO THE SIDE.
BECOMING AN AMERICAN, NOT JUST
AN IDEA.
IT'S A PROCESS AND A LIFELONG
PROCESS.
THIS GREAT NATION, SO MANY
BEAUTIFUL THINGS ABOUT IT AND
YOU ARE LEARNING THAT WHEN YOU
COME FROM THE COUNTRY THAT I
COME FROM AND THERE ARE A LOT
OF DIFFERENCES, FREEDOMS THAT
ARE MIND BLOWING FOR SOMEONE
WHO COMES FROM A COUNTRY LIKE
THAT.
MY QUESTION IS WHAT ARE THE
PRIORITIES FOR THIS
ADMINISTRATION.
YOU MENTIONED TITLE 42 WHERE
EVERYONE WANTS TO TALK ABOUT
WHAT IS HAPPENING ON THE
BORDER, THAT HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE LEAVING
THEIR HOMES, PACKING UP THEIR
FAMILIES AND BAGS TO COME UP
HERE BECAUSE THEY ARE SO
DESPERATE TO OR BECAUSE OF AN
ECONOMIC SITUATION BUT WHERE
ARE THE PRIORITIES WHERE YOU
HAVE DEMOCRATS OR REPUBLICANS
BEGGING FOR ANSWERS, WHAT WE
ARE GOING TO DO COME WEDNESDAY
WENT TITLE 42 GOES AWAY BUT
THERE'S NO ANSWER YET.
WHY WE TALKING IMMIGRATION
EXAMS, WHEN WE HAVE A CRISIS AT
THE BORDER?
LISA: WE ARE EXPECTING THE
FLOODGATES, UP TO 15,000
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS, THAT GETS
TO THE SACREDNESS OF BE AN
AMERICAN, WHICH YOU KNOW HAVING
SERVED THIS COUNTRY SO BRAVELY.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS?
JOEY:WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COME HERE
LEGALLY IS THERE AND RAMPANT.
YOU HAVE TO ANSWER 6/10
QUESTIONS.
AS OF 2020 DONALD TRUMP DOUBLED
THAT, 12 OUT OF 20.
100 FACTS ABOUT OUR COUNTRY.
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THOSE FACTS
WE REMEMBERED OVER 12 OR 13
YEARS OF SCHOOLING, PROBABLY
YEARS TO LEARN IT BECAUSE YOU
CAN'T JUST BECOME A CITIZEN.
THROUGH THE IMMIGRATION AND
CITIZENSHIP SERVICES WEBSITE,
YOU'RE DOING AN INTERVIEW WITH
A BASIC UNDERSTANDING OF
ENGLISH AND ANSWER 6/100 FACTS,
IT IS DIFFICULT.
I APPRECIATE THAT BUT IT'S NOT
ABOUT MAKING YOU EARN YOUR
CITIZENSHIP BUT MAKING SURE YOU
UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU ARE
BECOMING.
IF YOU DON'T KNOW THE
CONSTITUTION HOW MUCH CAN YOU
BE TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF AS A
CITIZEN, IF YOU DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE BILL OF
RIGHTS ARE, HOW DO YOU STAND UP
FOR YOURSELF AS A CITIZEN?
THE IDEA THIS IS PUNITIVE, YOU
DON'T TURN CITIZENSHIP, YOU
PARTAKE IN IT.
DON'T KNOW FAT IS THE PERFECT
WAY OF DOING IT BUT I DIDN'T
EARN IT WHEN I WAS BORN HERE, I
JUST EARN IT BY MILITARY
SERVICE, THIS TEST, ANSWERING 6
OR 10 QUESTIONS OUT OF 100 MAY
SEEM ENTER MOUNTABLE DONATIONS
SURMOUNTABLE.
YOU CAN SHOW YOUR KNOWLEDGE IN
ANOTHER WAY.
THE TEST IS ORAL FOR A REASON,
YOU HAVE TO TAKE TIME TO LEARN
ENOUGH ENGLISH TO SHOW YOU ARE
PROFICIENT IN IT.
I DON'T KNOW THERE IS SOMEBODY
OUT THERE, YOU SAID DECLARATION
OF INDEPENDENCE, SHOULD HAVE
SAID CONSTITUTION, EXPLAIN THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE TWO.
THERE'S LOTS OF OPPORTUNITIES
TO ORALLY PASS THIS TEST.
IF THAT IS WHAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS DOING, THEY
ARE THROWING RED MEAT TO THE
BONE, NOT DOING IT TO CHANGE
ANYTHING.
LISA: IT SEEMS LIKE THIS LACK
OF RESPECT FOR AMERICA, AMERICA
SHOULD BE THIS SACRED THING, WE
SHOULD MAKE IT DIFFICULT TO
COME HERE, IT SHOULD BE
SOMETHING SPECIAL.
>> IT DEGRADES THE SACRIFICE OF
PEOPLE SITTING AT THIS TABLE
WHO NOT ONLY OFFERED THEIR
LIVES BUT LEFT THEIR HOMELAND
TO PURSUE THIS IDEAL.
WHEN YOU DIMINISH THAT OR MAKE
IT SO SIMPLE IT IS LIKE A
TURNSTILE, I DO WORRY YOU ARE
DIMINISHING OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS, BY TRASH TALKING THE
POLICE AND MAKING THEM THE
ENEMY OR REDUCING WHAT THEY DO
EVERY DAY AND THE RISKS THEY
TAKE.
WE PUT OURSELVES IN A POSITION
WHERE PEOPLE DON'T WANT TO BE
COPS AND PUBLIC SAFETY IS
THREATENED.
I WORRY WHEN WE START
DISLOCATING WHAT IT MEANS TO BE
AN AMERICAN IN TEACHING AND
PASSING THAT ON TO THOSE WHO
WANT TO BE.
WE GET LESS OF AN AMERICA WHEN
IT IS OVER.
NOT ONLY THOSE COMING IN BUT
THOSE WHO ARE ALREADY HERE.
LISA: I DON'T KNOW WE CAN MAKE
IT MORE DIFFICULT FOR PEOPLE TO
BECOME AMERICANS.
I WANT THIS AMERICAN DREAM FOR
EVERYONE.
MOST MAGICAL THING THAT HAS
EVER HAPPENED TO MY FAMILY AND
MYSELF BUT I THINK ABOUT IT ALL
THE TIME.
WHAT AMERICANS WANT IS MORE
ORGANIZATION.
THEY WANT TO KNOW HOW THE
PROCESS IS WORKING AND WHEN
THEY SEE WHAT IS HAPPENING AT
THE SOUTHERN BORDER IT LETS
THEM DOWN.
THERE'S NO CONTROL OVER THE
SITUATION.
>> LAWLE